-Welcome back.
I'm here with Nicole Holofcener,
Ben Affleck, and Matt Damon,
the stars of "The Last Duel,"
the writers of "The Last Duel."
Thank you again for being here.
You filmed a lot of this
in Ireland.
It is a massive movie,
by the way.
And what I love about it
is how much --
I appreciate how much work
goes into movies,
from writing to getting it made,
getting it produced,
but then doing it, filming it,
then doing also press for it.
But I know it's years
of your life.
-Yeah. Yeah.
-It's a lot of work.
-It's a lot.
I mean, this is, you know,
a few years of work,
of, like, a lot of thought
and care and love
and all that stuff.
I mean, and then we got
interrupted by COVID, of course,
kind of halfway through, so --
-Yeah, you stayed
in Ireland, right?
-I did, yeah, I stayed.
We shut down right when
we got to Ireland,
and my family and I,
we just took a vote.
We decided to stay.
And it was a great decision.
We had a great time there
and kind of got absorbed
into this beautiful
little community there.
-Where exactly were you?
-We were in Dalkey.
We were just near Dublin.
And it's this great little town,
and we were as lucky
as you could get, really.
-I heard a story that you
FaceTimed the mayor of Dalkey.
-The mayor of Dalkey,
Bono, yeah.
-Bono.
-I FaceTimed him the night
that my wife and I
had a few drinks.
-Okay.
-It was a Friday night,
and I had let the kids
dye my hair red.
Like, we --
-That's what a dad does.
-Yeah, I was their art project,
basically.
And it was clear that
we weren't going back to work,
and so then we decided --
they decided --
-There's nothing
children like more
than to humiliate their parents.
-Than to humiliate their father,
right.
-Oh, yeah.
-But then they decided
that I needed a Mohawk.
I don't even know --
And so they Mohawked me,
and that was the night
I FaceTimed him.
And he was like,
"What are you doing?"
And that's what we were --
-He's like,
"I'm starting a band."
-Yeah, here's a picture
of Matt Damon's hair.
Look at this thing.
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-It's Travis Bickle.
And actually the hair,
it's even more ridiculous.
That's a black-and-white
that my wife took on her phone.
But the hair
was actually maroon.
I looked like a rooster.
I looked ridiculous.
-What did Bono say
when you FaceTimed him?
-He was like,
"What have you done?
What is happening over there?"
-Like, "Go back to America."
-Like, "Do you need help?
Do we need to come help you?"
-"Shall I send someone?"
-Yeah. Well, I can't thank you
enough for writing this
and making this project real.
-Thanks.
-And it's a great story.
People got to check it out.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Matt Damon and
Jodie Comer in "The Last Duel."
Take a look.
-You knew what would happen
to me should you lose this duel.
You knew and you didn't tell me.
-God will not punish those
who tell the truth.
-My fate and our child's fate
will be written
not by God's will,
but by which old man
will die first.
-How dare you speak to me
this way?
-What have I to lose?
I begged you
to find another way,
and now I might be burned alive.
-I am risking my life for you.
-Mm.
You are risking my life
so you can fight your enemy
and save your pride.
And that could render
our child an orphan.
Or did you not think of that?
-Nicole Holofcener, Ben Affleck,
Matt Damon.
"The Last Duel"
is in theaters Friday.